the Joe Rogan experience you're you're
supposed to be there to do justice to
the experience of these two guys going
at it and giving their all but I
supposed to be hoping one guy yeah
that's true but it's also really hard
for me when a friends fighting you know
yeah Daniel Cormier fights is very hard
for me to see him very hard
yeah my last fight was steep a and I
love steep a two but to watch steep a
beat the [ __ ] out of Daniel was rough it
was really hard
yeah because Daniel is such a good guy I
love that guy and to watch him eat those
left hooks to the body and then get
beaten downs like oh that must be hard
and I'm commentating on it like it's an
amazing thing I'm watching right right
it is amazing so it's hard to separate
you know when Brendan Schaub was
fighting it was the hardest that was the
hardest because I was good friends with
him yeah I knew he really didn't want to
fight anymore
and I was like God God that's that's
really that must be really hard it was
when he doesn't want to fight anymore
and he's just getting beaten he was
getting beaten and he was getting beaten
bad and I didn't I didn't see an end to
it who's the guy with the nose that went
crooked like this recently Mike Perry oh
that sure is crazy Craig I can't believe
someone can continue fighting when their
nose is literally across her face that
dude's a savage I mean you have to be a
savage like 100% bona fide
dyed-in-the-wool like he literally like
imagine what he's fighting through when
he has his his his nose over here it's
his face has to be complete and numb
well well no no no no or I mean I don't
know I don't really know pain
okay massive pain the sinuses are one of
the most sensitive areas of your face
when you get your nose shattered first
of all you can't see your eyes are
watering and his nose is pouring blood
Oh mine's getting choked right he's in
the middle of getting Chuck Close like
oh that is the worst [ __ ] nose I've
ever seen in my life of all the years of
calling fights the only thing that comes
close is Rich Franklin when he fought
Anderson Silva pull up rich Franklin's
nose versus Anderson Silva and you'll
see similar but not quite as horrific
but the thing is about Rich Franklin was
bummed out about his nose whereas you
know Mike Perry was like [ __ ] yeah
he didn't you look at the one the far
left right there far left far left far
left right there click that one that's
the one where Anderson Silva sort of
reconstructed his nose it's hard to see
in that picture make it larger so that
that's his nose after yeah it's all
shifted off so yeah see how it looks all
[ __ ] up Wow but that ain't [ __ ]
compared to Mike Perry's Mike Perry's is
the worst nose in the history of the
sport today I mean what does he look
like now who's that guy's nose click on
that one in the middle above above let's
think drunk a little bit Jesus
Wow whose [ __ ] noses that Jesus it
went up into his forehead looks like
this worse nose breaks in the UFC who is
that dude yeah he looks like looks like
half his nose is is a up in his eyelids
oh my god that's just swelling right but
look how Bart shift Ryan mcgillivray
whoo that's rough Wow Jesus Christ
Wow yeah yeah not still smiling nose
he's still smiling there's Shogun
Shogun's nose got [ __ ] up too I think
that was against Jon Jones yeah kung Li
there Connolly's nose got shattered yeah
man and then you got to get it all
reconstructed and they got a sort of
Stitch the bones back together again cuz
if you get this bone shatters like oh
man there's not much there you know it's
such a tight if you feel that bone it's
like so gentle right so delicate yeah if
you take a knee they're like oh that's
how they're breaking it right yeah he's
all right now
well it looks pretty good damn they did
an amazing job breaking stories eating
pizza I mean yo ki pizza haha but the
crazy thing is his nose was look like
the worst situation that you could
possibly get in and his nose now looks
pretty normal
yeah or the other guys as noses are just
like that one guy with the bulge right
by his eyebrows lightning and his nose
is still curved to the right and you
smile and like you assume Mike Perry
would have that kind of nose after that
that kind of guys right after the fight
you know Mike Perry had to go through
extensive surgery yesyes well I was that
where does that fight take place
Uruguay yes oh yeah South America yeah
so he had a stay there
get really extensive surgery was there
for several days just to try to recover
before he could fly home the scary thing
is he's gonna get back in the ring [ __ ]
yeah is it loves it and then that that
bone that he's gonna have is gonna break
down again is it gonna be weaker or is
it gonna I wish I could tell you I don't
know you know really because imagine if
it just shatters again he's got to do it
again yeah we got his nose reconstructed
who's what is this not a UFC but it's
called the FC kicked in the face oh
that's the worst nose ever oh my
that's horrible oh my god yeah that's
the one that cries I said oh there the
guy in the bottom is a guy who got his
nose damaged somehow or another and they
grew it on his head oh it's a hard
business man
[Applause]